nobody that's a leader
would not do what i did and i know
there's a risk there's a danger but
that's okay
[Music]
i just left walter reed medical center
and i learned so much in moroni virus
don't
be afraid of it you're going to beat it
we have the best
medical equipment don't be afraid of it
feel great like better than i have in a
long time
i didn't feel so good don't
be afraid of it you're going to beat it
we have to put on a virus
don't be afraid of it and now i'm better
maybe i'm immune i don't know be afraid
of it don't
let it dominate don't let it take over
your life be afraid of it
don't let that happen you're the
greatest country in the world you're
afraid of it
as your leader i had to do that i knew
there's danger do it but i had to do it
but don't let it dominate your lives get
out there
be careful we have the best medicines in
the world
and it all happened very shortly and
they're all getting approved
and the vaccines are coming momentary
on a virus
all right everybody what a day what a
day we don't have any more time for that
the rare
evening stream uh we are standing by for
donald trump's third rally of the day
this one in
omaha nebraska and i you know
this is just i'm no political strategist
but
if a republican is in nebraska
seven days before an election my
instinct is things aren't going so well
you guys i'm sure know much more than i
do
but uh if in my mind if things are going
well for a republican candidate
an incumbent president no doubt i don't
imagine them in omaha
seven days before the election it is uh
what it must be 6
41 p.m in omaha are they is omaha one
hour behind east coast or two it's
either 7 41 or 6 i think it's 7 41 there
uh so it is night time and we are
awaiting the arrival of donald trump
nothing more fun
than being crammed together during a
global hundred-year pandemic
in the dark waiting for trump to show up
and say things like
suburban women must love me
or something like that so i have a lot
of different things to go over with you
guys today
i have memes i have messages i have
polling i have tweets i have
coveted numbers i almost said corvid
coveted numbers
what else do i have and i get oh i also
have i guess the update that trump is
running very very late so we uh
we may have time and by the way i will
say now
people seem to have been liking me not
doing the entire trump rally we just
sort of take a temperature of how insane
it is and
how few masks there are and how slurry
and orange donald trump is and then
sometimes we bail
since it's the rare nighttime stream i
was actually thinking
we may open up the phone lines during
the rally once we get bored of the rally
maybe if we get a goal you know maybe
i'll even go i'll go right now
to our event listen we put up 25 as the
goal
just as a sort of you know just to tease
people
really the goal is 50. i'll just put up
50 and if we get to 50
we'll just go to some discord calls even
while donald trump is speaking
after we get a sense of what donald
trump is going to say i think it'll be
an interesting thing
do you guys hear that
what on earth is going on oh hold on a
second
let me just take a phone call guys hold
on that was not discord that was not i
actually i know what that is
okay so in fact let me just uh i'm gonna
mute
there's a particular i see what's going
on people were calling our voicemail
and i have i have the voicemail page
open um
because i there was a voicemail i wanted
to play for you guys in a little bit so
needless to say
we uh we we will we i will just open the
phone lines i think
if uh things go well and we um
kind of get bored with the trump rally
okay before we go
anywhere let me get caught up on all the
messages people have
oh actually speak before we even get
into messages
um as some of you know i'm now on
uh cameo and one of the things on cameo
is you can pay to send me a message
and i i've never been trolled on cameo
but i got one today where
some guy spent five dollars to say
hello donkey i just found your youtube
the other day
and i got to say i fundamentally
disagree with you on many different
things relating to trump but free speech
period so understand that relating to
trump but
free speech period question
how will you react if trump wins over
biden
youtube rage tears
i hope that was worth five dollars to
this gentleman
and i used the term gentleman very very
loosely
okay let me go through what folks are
saying
over on twitch deeper shades of house
says thanks for the live stream and c
dubs says woohoo two months on twitch
love the show david thanks for being
a sobering voice in unprecedented times
i appreciate that
thank you uh over on youtube a lot of
messages coming in
dr chakuseki radiologist says so david i
think i may need a pacman sponsored
lobotomy
my puny liberal brain can't handle the
shock of acb's confirmation
mercy ban my brain i actually don't
think we should refer to her as acb
acb is sort of like rbg
aoc it's just i i think we should call
her
amy looney barrett that should just be
or or amy covid barrett
i don't like the idea of a three-letter
abbreviation
for someone who really doesn't doesn't
deserve it okay so i'm not going to be
doing that
jr says david i sent you the new new
theme song i made a few days ago with a
full band did you get it
i just voted two days ago in portland
oregon i i did get it i'm just so behind
on everything right now because it is
election uh
down to the last seven days wendy says
seven
thousand dollars a year gets you this
type of hair i guess referring to our
thumbnail
with trump's wild hair it's actually
seventy thousand a year
that trump wrote off uh for hair styling
azim abu khalil says if democrats attain
a house senate majority would impeaching
or replacing a judge
be less risky than expanding the court
uh it
may be less risky but it would be less
likely i actually tomorrow on the show
i am going to have an extremely powerful
segment
where i will actually go full bore
in favor of expanding the court i'm
ready to do it
and tomorrow on the show i will have a
segment where i
it's going to be extremely powerful and
i've been considering it
really strongly for a while tomorrow i
am going
fully in fully in on expanding the court
i'm going to give you my reason why
i am going to disabuse you of the false
notion that it would lead to some kind
of slippery slope where
every president will then add five seats
to the court no
no okay you understand
let's continue um
azim also coming in with is trump using
the supreme court to steal the election
a foregone conclusion
it's not a foregone conclusion but it's
a possibility
steven says hi from poland we're
demonstrating on the streets against the
anti-abortion law passed by poland
supreme court
is this the usa's future as well in
poland by activism we will stop this
will you i think we may see depending on
the outcome of the election
i think we may see some of the a biggest
pro
this i think what we will see if trump
steals the election with the court
occupy wall street will be nothing the
climate protests will be nothing
the women's march will be nothing the
george floyd protests
will be nothing if indeed this
is stolen at by the court may not change
anything
but i do think it's going to be
absolutely crazy ant and sharon say hey
david isn't this trump's third rally
today he's infecting the masses blessing
yeah
speaking of which let me get to that now
so yesterday
donald trump had three rallies one of
which was in a place um
in pennsylvania spelled l-i-t-i-t-z
and i on today's show i know it's not
pronounced
latits but i pronounced it lititz
a few times and i got some of the
funniest emails
um let me show these to you this is so i
actually have a bunch of things to show
i put it up on us on a word doc just
because i didn't know
how else to show it john said david
david david it's not latits
i loved it but it's pronounced lidditz
i love your show and help uh support you
giving the truth rose also saying david
love your show it's pronounced
pronounced lit it's not latits i know
guys i know and then also if you missed
yesterday's stream
extremely powerful numbers from last
week's debate this is from my youtube
rep
live views 317 000 peak concurrent
almost 57 000 this was our record watch
time off the charts
you led this is our stream last week you
led
left of center political publishers you
were in the top 20 streams for last
night's debate hell yeah
i think you're actually at 15 or 16 you
actually edged nbc news on peak
concurrent viewers
but they beat you on live views kudos on
a great live stream can you imagine
our little youtube channel uh last week
the top independent left wing media
stream
of all youtube and 15th or 16th
including including um corporate media
uh putting us extremely strongly
extremely strongly in position
for uh for election night i guess i
would say
unknown prodigy says david pakman is a
late
a male chakaseki says deepak loves total
recall therefore
is a quaid a male oh god
not so sure about this guys uh cameo kid
says so powerfully fashionably late mr
david pakman
and cameron says hey david can you do a
piece to speak to the motives of vernon
jones australia is with you
all right i'll look into that um so
i i correct me if i'm wrong is trump
arriving by chopper meaning that we're
just seeing the first of probably four
helicopters arrive can anybody confirm
that
i'm having a hard time telling what's
going on because the
the the uh the covid is blocking my view
it's just there's too much covet i can't
clearly see what's happening
anybody know choppers
let's listen
[Music]
okay yeah that's not that's not good all
right um very good so that
that is that all right as far as
uh okay people joining and asking about
phone lines
yeah i actually i may open phone lines
tonight if we get to 50 website members
and patrons i'll even take some calls
towards the end of the of the rally i
don't think we need to watch the full
rally
um but please consider grabbing a
membership at jointpakman.com
or making a pledge at patreon.com david
pakman show
we will start to fill up this blue bar
beautifully it's a beautiful shade of
blue i think you'll love it when you see
it
and uh yes the goal today is opening up
phone lines and as a reminder we now
take
calls via discord which you can find um
at davidpakman.com slash
discord that's d-i-s-c-o-r-d
which is um it's working really well i
think we've got
about 3 500 people already on our
discord which is great
it's working really really great all
right let's keep it going
tiamat says i miss the music let me
guess lee greenwood
uh not sure i know what you mean but uh
yes
what do we have here looks like the
chopper right guys am i wrong
maybe it is oh no i guess it is a plane
yeah i can't oh it is a plane oh it is a
plane all right
wendy says why does trump slur his words
it makes me think he's been drinking
trump doesn't drink as far as we know
but that's a real
question um a lot of people wonder about
that
quincy says from oklahoma i support
biden but so many people here support
trump because biden will take away oil
field jobs
brainwashed counter-argument ideas yes
replacing
dirty energy with clean energy will
create far more jobs than it destroys
that's really the argument
that's the argument there's no uh you
know
period full stop okay i do have another
voicemail i was holding on to this for
you guys
he when when uh you know when we talk
about the importance of supporting
independent media if you're progressive
i suggest supporting progressive
independent media but whatever
uh here's a little bit of insight into
what we're fighting
every day okay i had voicemails from
this guy for you guys yesterday
here is another voicemail that came in
today full warning
get the kids out of the room get the
kids out of the room this is not for
children this is not child
safe okay take a listen to this
no hold on oh i actually i
i muted because calls were coming in
here we go off we go
and from the top hey daniel prickles how
you doing
you queer [ __ ]
are you going to throw your arms around
so we can stick that microphone up your
big ass or have patty come and stick his
dick up here oh he's he's he doesn't
have a dick anyway you guys got real
problems as you can tell
neither do you you don't even have a set
of balls uh
how do you like our new uh supreme court
justice and we're gonna
and we're gonna take over the house the
senate and the presidency
all over again and then you people are
in real trouble maybe the supreme court
maybe amy
comey barrett will take and uh with bill
barr
and durham and a few other people and
get you people on free speech tv
and lock these all up
i bet you wouldn't play this on your
freaking uh
comedy show so remember
i don't know guy if this guy was my
kid's teacher i wouldn't mind
if i ever see i'm gonna stick that
microphone that
stand right up your ass and you love
every minute of it
you little [ __ ] go back to argentina
okay so so guys that's what we're
fighting
there's millions of those guys around
okay there's
millions of those people around that is
what we are fighting
and uh you know
i don't know what else to say i don't
know what else to say big
thank you to jeff meyerson jeff is new
member number
one today at joinpackman.com
also want to say a big thank you to
matthew ackermann
matthew ackerman is new member number
two
at joinedpakman.com and anastasia
is a new patron and it all counts guys
see here
website members and patrons so anastasia
is supporter number three today
uh we are very strongly looking for 50
and because it's the rare nighttime
stream if i'm here we might as well do
it right
uh i will open up phone lines if we get
to 50.
maybe even during the rally i don't know
that we need to see the full rally we'll
get a sense of trump's uh hue
and saturation today um and
his level of slur and that type of thing
and then we will we will continue
with the evening all right what else did
i have for you guys
uh oh and speaking of membership did you
guys see
what amy kovet barrett had written
on her stupid notepad it actually wasn't
so stupid it actually turned out that
she was
very she was looking at whether the
special we're offering is even
constitutional
she was actually it it's and you know
she is
in the uh what's it called the people of
praise that weird cult that she's part
of
uh the membership is legal in people of
praise but she's approaching this from a
constitutional originalist standpoint
and she is going to very powerfully look
into whether these discounts are or
aren't constitutional but until she does
that
take advantage of it you know take
advantage of it before they outlaw this
stuff because if they do
we're all going to suffer we're all
going to suffer and that'll be really
really ugly
all right other super chats coming in
william says david love the show
and the critical thinking series do you
think various rants on social media
could turn into probable cause and
fourth amendment issues
um i i don't know i'm not sure you i i
would need a little more information
about that
speaking of social media though one
thing just to show you from earlier
uh i don't know if you guys saw this as
you know this is kaylie
murkena a nanny and she is donald
trump's press secretary
she appeared on tv today as a trump 2020
senior advisor wait a second this is a
white house staffer and a campaign
staffer that doesn't make sense when
they were asked about this
they said oh she appeared on fox as a
private person
so she is the press secretary she's
identified as a campaign staffer and
they're like don't worry
this appearance was just kaylee speaking
as an individual
these people are just disgusting these
people are just
absolutely disgusting a big thank you
to matthew williams matthew is new
member number
four today at joinpackman.com
uh chris strom says philadelphia is just
going absolutely insane thanks to
right now what's going on is not a
protest i'm all for peaceful protests i
don't see color
i'm not sure what's going on in
philadelphia
shasha thanking me for the coverage
heroes have fur says hi david question
from my eight-year-old son jonah who's
watching he wants to know
how you know so much about elections um
[Music]
i don't know the answer to that i guess
just doing this show for more than a
decade
and you just pick up a little bit of
information at a time
and then hopefully you remember most of
it
i guess is what i would say jonah but
that's a great question the fact that
you're
asking that question puts you in upper
you're you're really a candidate for
upper management
payne hoover says hey david keep up the
good work could you tell zach to eat his
vegetables yeah vegetables are great i
highly recommend
broccolini is high on my list love
broccolini
i would say mushrooms but mushrooms
actually a fungus
i know that not so much youtube
twitch would destroy me if i called
mushrooms a vegetable i can see
it would probably end my my twitch
channel
but mushrooms a fungus fungus
corey woodrow says taco supreme court
justice amy bony carrot
is the most legitimate public servant
since mayor mccheese
well said well said super guy says trump
can only steal the election if it's
super close
vote absolutely absolutely
uh let's see it is the hourly
investigation as to whether i am reading
twitch
chat i am i am
uh wait a second are there people in the
chat who actually think mushrooms are a
vegetable
guys you've got to read the omnivore's
dilemma by michael pollan
you need to be disabused of the false
notion that a mushroom is a vegetable
it's not
it's really not jorah monothan
says if voting is for suckers call me mr
lollipop
voted today you rock dp yeah feel free
to check in via super chat let me know
if you voted where you voted and how you
voted
and maybe even if you have the the
characters
um whether anything crazy was going on
big thank you to mino demille for the
twitch sub
as well as finest one gaming okay it
looks like people want the phone lines
open uh if we get to 50 members we're
opening them up
i want to say big big thank you to
uh kalyn healey who is new member number
five
brandon kurtz is number six sandy
williams is number seven
marcus webster number eight and philip
vaughn
is new member number nine uh the deal i
made and it's a deal with the devil
it's really a deal with you guys but uh
we will
we'll start with this with the rally but
if we do get to 50 members i'll just
open take some phone calls and see
what's on people's minds we've seen a
lot of these rallies
uh we'll get a flavor for probably in
the in the first 15 seconds
but uh you know in the first 15 minutes
for sure
and on that note jonathan markham is new
member number 10
and jack mills is new member number 11.
very good
okay let's see what else is on people's
minds
and i know that it is a lot uh hold on i
don't want to miss anybody
valerie king says he has no campaign
money so he's just rallying there's no
middle ground
voters going to these coveted fairs does
he even want to win
great question hot mustard gas says did
you see if you could interview talia
lavin
who wrote culture warlords a jewish
woman getting inside white nationalist
groups yet we reached out to her today
hot mustard gas asked for me to
interview talia lavin
on a recent stream i sent that request
to producer pat
producer pat reached out to talia today
and i hope we'll have her on the show
soon
i listen to you guys i listen to you
guys
phoenix says do you think trump is
having so many rallies because there
will be no reason to have him after the
election
he needs his flock to feed his ego yeah
there's actually a really good piece
don't remember if it was vanity fair or
the atlantic
about how these are essentially ego
stroking fests that the people who are
here
are already trump diehards i mean listen
if you're willing to risk
covid to go see this guy talk and say
the same thing he always says
you're already voting for him and um
i i think it is all ego oliver says if
biden wins november 3rd do you think
mitch mcconnell will end the senate
recess
early to gear into trump rampage
overdrive
no i mean it's scheduled to end on
november 9th
so i think i i don't think we're going
to see it end early
but by the way i don't know how many
people saw my tweet earlier whoa
saw my tweet earlier today mitch
mcconnell got amy coney barrett
confirmed in direct opposition to his
stated principles from 2016
and then immediately adjourned the
senate guaranteeing no coronavirus
stimulus before the election guy's
disgusting
guy's disgusting he has a challenger he
does
uh okay we have just moments left until
we hear
the sweet rantings of trump so let me
see if i can get caught up on new
members and get an
updated number for you john donahue is
number 12 today
alex zahn is number 13.
zachary bell is number fourteen ryan
deegan number 15
kai olson is number 16
jt cordycek is number
17 justin balandi
is number 18 claudia
is number 19 and michael gutzmer is new
member number 20.
and remember phones open at 50 even if
the rally is still going on
uh let's see if that stupid country
music song is playing yet
every american heart yep it is it is
no uh no question whatsoever thanks to
super clove for the sub
on twitch with the message thanks for
everything you do david
fatty mcblunts oh wait no that's fatty
mcblunt's junior actually
it's fatty's oh no it is fatty mcblunts
okay fatty mcblunts has subscribed with
prime
and party 1999 has subscribed with the
message
person woman man camera tv
an excellent message an excellent
message
uh theo hall asks if biden wins will you
keep live streaming i hope so it's often
the highlight of my day
unfortunately guys my career as a
streamer ends
the day donald trump leaves that's very
very sad for some people but it's good
news for others
i'm kidding i'm kidding no we are going
to continue uh streaming
various elements of government even
after uh
whenever no matter what happens that's
for sure
uh okay let's see we are really down to
our last moments before trump starts
here so i'm just going to
keep going rudy gobert hold on isn't
rudy gobert's celtics player
rudy gobert rudy gobert is new member
number 21
and la's dazara is new member number 22.
we will hear the genius of trump very
soon let's see what's happening
i'd love to hear him explain why he is a
republican and he's in nebraska with
seven days to go that would be a great
thing to hear
that's a lot of people that's people
it's already weird
that's incredible i hope the fake news
media is turning their cameras way
way back there
[Applause]
and i have to also say because a lot of
people are here from
iowa hello iowa
okay wait a minute who's from iowa race
go
[Applause]
[Music]
who's from omaha
he should actually do what dave rubin
once did cultural critic dave reuben
during a stand-up act
pulled the audience on their sexual
orientation asking who's gay in the
audience maybe trump that could he
he's only half a step from that here
and we're gonna win four more years in
the great white house that beautiful
beautiful wine
this is look at this i can't believe
this
29 000 people can you believe it
wait is he saying there's 29 000 people
there
there's no way right we have to win both
nebraska's you know that right
got to be ridiculous we're going to win
both
this election is a choice
super recovery which is what we're
having or a biden
depression sad to say
and some bad news just came out on biden
but i won't tell you about that you'll
find that out tomorrow
[Applause]
man that's something biden has pledged
the biggest
tax hike in the history of our country
first man
taxes go down for the bottom 95
under biden i'm going to raise your
taxes what's going on
i gave working families record-setting
tax cuts
and in my second term i will cut
middle-class taxes very
substantially more
and by the way a lot of things are going
on you're seeing those poll numbers are
going through the roof i hate to tell
where is the fake news it's over there
oh that's a lot of cameras
oh it's going up they're very concerned
they're very very concerned all over
florida is looking great
now nebraska we know it's looking great
okay then why is he there
i mean in theory i didn't really have to
be here but it's nice to be with your
friends too
and there it is your vote we will
continue to bring back our jobs support
our police defend our second amendment
which is
under siege secure our borders maintain
american energy
independence expand school choice
and ensure more products are proudly
stamped with the phrase
that beautiful phrase beautiful
phrase made in the usa
right not like his own campaign gear
record prosperity
epic job growth and a safe vaccine that
eradicates the virus and quickly ends
the pandemic
and we're making that final turn they
don't want to hear it
we're making that turn you know that
right
we're going to have the vaccine anyway
with or without it
we're making details 70 more people died
during the rally fully
resumed that's all we want we want
normal life
normal life go back seven months we'll
take normal life
greatest economy we ever had we want
normal life and next year will be the
greatest economic year
in the history of our country that's
where we're heading
superb joe biden doesn't even respect
you enough to campaign he never came
here right did he come here
oh all right so that's the end of that
i'll see you guys moments ago we learned
about the other reason joe biden has
been hiding in his basement
in a national television interview
do you want me to tell you the rest oh
no is he going to do it
the biden family's business partner
revealed shocking disturbing and
explosive information about joe biden's
corrupt
and illicit foreign business dealings
stories not landlords
the business partner made clear that
biden's denial of involvement
in his son's corrupt business dealings
was a blatant lie with proof
he stated with first-hand knowledge that
vice president biden
was directly and personally involved in
establishing
corrupt business dealings with china and
getting money for it this all happened
at the same time as biden was letting
china
steal american jobs and plunder american
wealth you saw that for eight years
if biden wins china wins and china
will own the usa if biden wins biden
wins the world win bad things
by the way he's not a good guy just
where are the masks by the way
[Applause]
lock them up
[Applause]
this is the law and order crowd chanting
to lock people up with no due process
or even having been accused of a crime
rather be than
a trump rally on about a 10 degree
evening 10 degrees
it's cold out here but that's okay you
know we just left wisconsin
it was cold and we left michigan it was
called and raining
and i said i won't put on a hat because
i'm going to show you how tough we are
that was a tough one
what a tough guy huh it was pouring and
it was freezing and he didn't wear a hat
this is right here i hate to tell you
well it's a little later
it's an honor to be with you i have to
say when we win
you win nebraska wins and all of america
wins and that's the way we want it
where did trump get gloves so small it
must be a kid's clothing the last 47
year
let's think of it 47 47 years
outsourcing your jobs opening your
borders
and sacrificing american blood and
treasure
in endless foreign ridiculous wars
now republicans claim to be against wars
isn't that so funny
nebraska voted to fire this corrupt
political establishment
and you elected an outsider as president
who finally
put america first
and if i don't sound like a typical
washington politician it's because
i'm not a politician
if i don't always play by the rules of
the washington establishment
it's because i was elected to fight for
you and i fought harder for you
than any president who's ever held this
wonderful beautiful
[Applause]
this officer is a matter of economic
survival
for omaha and for communities all across
our country
joe biden's agenda and i'm not sure it's
zoe biden's agenda let's face it
that's not his agent it sounds nice
spiders are generic the guy's shot
guys is jazza he's so good he's not buys
his agenda
took them away i was in pennsylvania
with his tremendous like crowds like
this and
tremendous rallies and he had the lid on
right you know the lid like from a
garbage can they call it the lid
and they saw what was happening because
i went to three of them i did three of
them yesterday in pennsylvania so
he went from delaware to the closest
point where pennsylvania hits delaware
which was about five minutes away from
his basement
and he made a speech just before that he
called me george he said george i think
he was talking about george
and his wife was sitting next to home
and see you could see she was not happy
but it's hard to correct them you know
the camera's on but he called me george
and then he did the
little speech and it wasn't good they
sort of just moved him out they took him
away his own people brushed them off
they took them off stage
this is not what you can have you know
we have the greatest country in the
world we have more potential than any
country in the world
we can't play games
we can't play games so the democrats
let's say the democrats the radical left
democrats
they have an extreme agenda he's just a
vehicle he'll be there for about four
weeks or so
and then you'll have kamala kamala
it's not gonna be that will not be the
first
woman president you're gonna have a
woman president maybe soon
maybe soon but you're not gonna have
kamala it can't be kamala
she's further left by far
than crazy bernie you know bernie is
like a conservative compared to her
but biden's extreme agenda includes a
radical
vision to destroy suburbs across our
nation
how are your suburbs doing don't ask
are they good they won't be good for
longer thinking
and to completely dismantle law
enforcement and crippled police
departments nationwide you know what's
going on you see it better than anybody
you don't have to take my word for it
biden's plan
to destroy suburbs and police just take
a look
roll the tape we do this view on this
freezing cold night
the suburbs today are not the suburbs of
half a century ago the suburbs are
far more diverse than the cities but
they're being
targeted being targeted for what
federalized centralized government
control
by the left democrats want to abolish
the suburbs they are too clean and nice
and therefore by definition they are
racist the biden campaign has highly
specific plans
on how to do this it's called
affirmatively furthering fair housing
it's a hud regulation
it was written during the obama
administration biden's advisors plan to
enforce it
towns will be ordered to abolish zoning
for single-family housing
because single-family homes needless to
say are racist
low-income federally subsidized
apartments will go up in the suburbs
we'll also build 1.5 million new
energy-efficient homes
and public housing units
thankfully trump repealed this rule back
in july
but now the left is backing an even more
radical plan
it was a bill put forward by senator
cory booker to push low-income housing
developments
sorry i had a tech issue did i miss the
video federal takeover of local zoning
laws in essence
and biden he fully supports it
[Music]
the prior administration piled up more
than 600
major new regulations a cruel and
punishing region look at the look on
trump's space while this place
average american an additional 2
300 per year think of that the average
american
two thousand three hundred dollars
regulation
hitting low-income americans by we're
actually getting a look at
the look trump probably has on his face
when he's sitting at the white house
just watching fox news and stuff when he
comes on
one hundred dollars every single year
i've had the luxury of
enjoying the benefit of him he just
loves seeing himself on tv yeah that's
allowed me to grow my businesses
i believe that if you take into account
it seems titillated
trump tax cut you take into account the
drop in unemployment and particularly
unemployment for african americans the
lowest it's ever been in history
how's the economy right now we're loving
it kennedy credits
trump tax cuts and deregulation for her
company's growth it's the first time
in 10 years that it's booming again the
tax cuts
that were imposed did wonders for the
the middle class i will cut taxes even
further
for hardworking moms and dads i will not
raise taxes i will cut them
first how delusional and narcissistic is
to play videos of yourself at your own
rallies
[Music]
do you believe there is systemic racism
in law enforcement
absolutely i've been a police officer
for nearly 32 years
joe biden does not have the backs of
police officers
joe biden's staffers that gave money to
a fund
to help bail out accused criminals joe
biden's silence is encouraging the
rioters
kamala harris was working to help the
instigators the criminals get out of
jail
if joe biden's elected it's just going
to continue everyone beware
because they're not going to stop
the only person that defended the police
is trump what a stupid problem support
from police up above this trump really
like that i want to use the
responsibilities assigned to the police
and redirect some of the funding for
police do we agree that we can redirect
some of the funding
yes absolutely and joe biden's america
will all be in danger
if you support the police and you want
to be safe in your home and you want
your children safe
support donald trump
what the hell is going on
thank you very much well that's pretty
effective
you know what that costs to bring to you
tonight
it's weird to show that to people
already at the rally right like that's a
strange thing these people are already
voting for him they're
you know he could shoot people and
they'd vote for him thank you very much
pretty effective right you see it it
saves me a lot of words i can sit here
watch i say see
nah he's not the right guy he's not the
right guy he's not right for this
country
he's not he's not the guy for this
country this election
is a choice between the american dream
which is what we want
and a socialist nightmare which is where
you would head
if you ever had that which i don't
believe you'll do it's a choice between
a trump boom and a biden lockdown he
wants to lock it all down
now we close it up we understand the
disease it's a terrible thing
should never have been allowed to come
here from
china should never have been allowed
joe biden will delay the vaccine
postpone
therapies prolong the pandemic shudder
your schools right shudder your schools
destroy your small businesses and shut
down
our country we're not doing that look we
are setting records 11.4 million people
it's all opened up
we understand it and we are doing a job
we are literally setting records are
things open or closed because yesterday
he was saying everybody needs to open
now he's saying it is open biden will
close what you're doing in nebraska
look at how you're doing in nebraska
biden even wants to lock down young and
healthy americans yet
for those under the age of 50 i hate to
say this
under the age of 50. how many are under
the age of 50.
pretty young well i have good news for
you
99.99 okay you know what that means that
means you're in good shape
yesterday it was 0.98 but you notice the
fake
news now right all they talk about is
kovid kovetkovic
kovet koven and we've made such progress
it's incredible excuse me
i'm here
i mean i wasn't exactly feeling great
it's been a long time i wasn't exactly
feeling great
and i met with the great doctors one
thing when you're president you got
plenty of doctors
we have one of them here tonight i think
right we have our great white house
doctors traveling shawty's become very
famous
where's sean guy's a doofus oh is that
sean look at sean
look at him wow
you know he's got a big ego he loves it
when i mentioned his thing
now he's a great doctor and they were
great doctors
he'll be out if biden wins for sure
walter reed and everything else and
uh what we know today is like so
different than what we knew
six months ago incredible right the
progress now we're sure
trump failed we only suspected six
months ago even without we're turning
that corner you know at some point
we're turning that corner and it's been
pretty amazing uh
florida had a rough time boom it's step
back
it's all the way down texas all the way
down
arizona great governors all the way down
biden's cruel and senseless lockdowns
would cause
countless deaths from suicide drug
overdose
and delayed medical care alcohol
i mean so many so many different
problems remember i'd say
the cure cannot be worse than the
problem itself
that's what you have when i banned
travel from china
remember he said now he says oh we
should have done it sooner except when i
banned it
for two and a half months he said he
shouldn't do that he's xenophobic right
and now he says oh i should have done it
earlier
and he had a thing called the swine flu
it was a disaster yeah biden had it much
less lethal he was a it was a disaster
he was a disaster
he's still a disaster actually if we
listen to joe
countless more people would have died
they were anticipating it could be this
girl has moments where she seems to
think that
this may have been a stupid idea and
trump doesn't know what he's talking
about is too many as far as i'm
concerned
one is too many this shouldn't have
happened one is too many
but it could have been 2.2 it could have
been more than that
biden was willing to sacrifice your
lives
on the altar of open borders he wants
open
borders without borders you don't have
without borders you don't have a country
by the way the wall is now
over 400 miles
now it's over 400. and we're building 10
miles a week and it's very soon going to
be finished so we have the strongest
southern border we've ever had
and we want people to come into our
country but they have to come in legally
and they have to come in through merit
merit
biden has no plan no idea no clue he has
no clue that's for sure and he just
wants to lock up and
throw away the keys letting rioters and
looters run wild
and you know it's interesting they call
them peaceful protesters
they burn down your cities they do
things that nobody's seen before
all in radical left democrat
run cities and states but cities all of
them
check out my video about that and the
reality that cities are just run by
democrats i know we're coming in
the night before we came in they gave up
they left they took over a piece of
seattle that wasn't going to last
minneapolis the same thing we went into
minneapolis
we went in you know we have to be asked
in theory by the state
we went into minneapolis and it all
ended it took about
what do you think 25 minutes or so it
was just boom
right down the street now you know the
republican-run cities are doing very
well
the republican run
and i hope you agree because i know he's
here but you have a very good
republican governor you do know that
right really struggling here to speak
listen to that good good hi pete
good pete i'm glad they did that you
know i want to do the
otherwise i just wouldn't introduce you
later you know keep it quiet
they like you pete the biden plan will
crush you
and cry my plan will crush
the virus and you will see economic
benefits like we've never seen
in our country before that's where we're
handled
when the china plague arrived we moved
heaven and earth
to fight the disease we airlifted
medical supplies
pioneered groundbreaking therapies
reduced the fatality rate
85 think of that and saved over 2
million lives
our excess mortality rate has been 42
percent less
than europe you hear about europe he
doesn't know what these numbers mean by
the way i see a lot of people are
getting
disgusted with what's going on i do have
an offer open to to open the phone lines
at uh at 50 members
maybe we'll just make it 40 because
maybe maybe people can't
tolerate another one of these but i i
will open phone lines
you know first lady had it i had it
barrett had it they said sir baron has
tested positive
melania said sir you gave me coving he's
okay now sir he threw it away
he just took that through it away you
know they're young
they have strong immune systems but i'd
like to say the treatment didn't do
anything for me
doctor do you hear that didn't i just
threw it away like baron but you know
what
i wasn't going to take my chance i said
you have something give it to me
wow how privileged effective because i
woke up the next morning after being
with these doctors
they wanted to touch every single part
of your body and i didn't like it
12 of them each one was a specialist
right
every single one but they were great no
they were great but i woke up the next
morning
and i i'll tell you i felt like super
relatable for the president to say he
had
too many doctors attending to him when
we have millions of people with no
health insurance
and you know i don't have the luxury of
staying in a basement i'm president of
the united states
i don't i can't be staying i really
can't you can't stay
i had a lot of meetings i meet a lot of
people as president
i have that obligation so we have
basements in the white house i could say
we have beautiful bedrooms upstairs at
the white house i could stay for a year
and a half
i can't do that i have to be working for
you
and if something happens that happens
and i get you know they came in they
said
sir you've tested positive i said tested
positive for what
then you go into one of the 27 different
names corona
there's this china virus the china
plague
the china plank that's what i tested
positive for but it was amazing and it
was actually an experience and
until i came along you were supposed to
have lifetime immunity right
i said well you know i'm recovered i
feel great and i'm immune i could jump
right into this road i could kiss
every man and woman every man but
because it was me the press said no it's
not for a lifetime it's only for four
months the immunity is only now for four
months
nobody's talked about lifetime for a
lifetime now it's four months so what
are you gonna do
what are you gonna do it's one of those
things but i guarantee you this
on november 4th you won't be hearing as
much about this it's going to be right
now it's
it's kovind kovitkova no matter what
happens covet coven
and on november 4th i'll probably try
and find some information about it no
great place for a rally guys we're
rounding that beautiful turn
and it's going to be very good the
vaccines are going to make it go away a
lot faster
and they're going to be great the
greatest companies the greatest
companies of their kind in the world are
doing it
really good johnson and johnson moderna
they really are great pfizer thanks to
our relentless efforts
97 of all current emergency room visits
are for something other than the virus
think of that 97 percent
we're in great shape that's a
meaningless head in the one area
little areas in the midwest certain
areas that are trump's like there are so
many different medical conditions that
lead to people going to the emergency
room
two weeks they're figuring they'll go
down just like they did in florida texas
arizona and so many others
we're on track to deliver 100 million
doses of a safe vaccine
and a great vaccine and that's all set
we're all set logistically our military
is going to deliver it
it'll be done very quickly we will
vanquish the vaccine and
we will get rid of this whole thing good
good super chat
it'll be very you watch it's going to
happen
very quickly and we're going to have our
country back
and the whole world is going to be
coming back this was a terrible terrible
thing that happened
terrible thing that happened
terrible things that happened joe biden
has made a corrupt bargain in exchange
for
his party's nomination he has handed
control of his party over to the
rage-filled
socialists
no we got a couple of them too
unfortunately i would love the list of
communists controlling joe biden's
campaign we'll be running
your government it's not going to happen
by the way by the way just so you know
we are so far you listen to the fakers
back there look at them
you listen to the fake news we are so
far ahead
this is gonna be bigger than four years
ago by the way get out and vote
you gotta that's the only thing
i mean i'm standing here freezing
i ask you one little favor get the hell
out and vote
if someone sends me the clip of this
alec that you're talking about
i'd like to check it out at least you're
down there with each other
i'm on your email
this election day you must stop the
anti-american radicals and
really i mean that's what they are
they're radicals we can solve these
problems so quickly
if the governments would just say would
you please come in federal government
we stop it in a matter of minutes it
goes so fast
the radicals delivering joe biden you
have to do this
you have to deliver them a message the
far left
a thundering defeat at the ballot box on
november 3rd
wow it's got to be a big one
we've got to win big and we're going to
win big you know i'm watching them and
they're getting
like three weeks ago i don't know they
were doing these fake polls and they
felt very good and then
a week ago they were feeling okay
they're not feeling so good right now
they're saying these are not good
numbers
was that one of the greatest evenings
ever
four years ago
what a great day and i say this is
easier there's more
look at this crowd i mean we had big
crowds we'd never had crowds like this
look at this crowd 29 000.
you have you know you have 29 you have
29 000
people in omaha that's pretty good
and you're all on television say hello
you're on national television
see all the red lights that means the
cameras are going
that means those cameras are going 29
000 people they say
29 000. yeah
you know who uh spoke today president
barack hussein obama
here we go with hussein
he had 12 people in seven cars did you
hear them
no he draws he draws flies i've never
seen he just
he had no he had literally had a fly on
him on the other
and he brought bon jovi along you know
what happened to bon jovi he bore
he increased the crowd by 22 people the
ort board
and then joe spoke and that crowd left
and we have 29 000 people here and we
had a tremendous crowd in michigan
that'd be 2 900 people right or maybe
800 people
29. they're trying to figure out like if
trump is getting these crowds and if
biden's getting like 12 people
you know the circles he fills in the
circles they got like five of them
and a lot of times they put reporters in
there because they have no people
but today he tried to blame that on
covet also
he said no no we don't seek large crowds
because we want it because of the the
virus right they don't want the large
crowd
yeah that's not the reason okay just
that's not the reason
it's a hell of an excuse because of this
right
we're thrilled to be joined by the man
we were just talking about he's a friend
of mine
he loves his state he loves his country
and he's a great governor pete
ricketts pete pete ricketts dear god
great job what a good guy what a good
man
how's your state doing pete all right
good how are we doing by the way we're
going to be okay here right
he says good okay thank you very much
pete
and his brother todd another one really
good now there's only two people that
are better joe
and marlene now todd is great but they
will both admit
joe and marlene are better right and
you're here
right hi joe i like that hi joe
you got to be proud of you boys they're
doing a great job thank you very much
thank you very much great family here as
well our senators
deb fisher who's fantastic
she is my favorite senator from the
state
of nebraska right
by far by far she's fantastic
she is i'll tell you what she calls me
it doesn't stop
between her and joni ernst for from iowa
who i think is here where's joni
joni joni
they call sir we need help with ethanol
sir we need help with
corn we need it's always but you know
what that's what a great senator that's
what it is always
sir sir sir joni thank you very much and
i heard you're doing very well i just
saw some very nice numbers
and deb you don't have to worry about
numbers right
right you don't have to worry about
numbers i'm with you all the time thank
you both
and uh yeah it looks very good in iowa
thank you very much
good and representatives
jeff a warrior wizard
i'm a warrior thank you jeff great
great guy don bacon don
bacon give me a break
wow wow
well i like him too but i don't know if
i like him that much
that's very good
i'll tell you you better get me omaha do
you understand that i said
now i know i wouldn't have asked her but
now i'm going to say make sure we win
this side too
right that's a bacon crowd if i've ever
seen one
not good i'm very impressed that's about
as good as i've heard in a long time
and adrian smith hey
great job great job great to have you
here
it's a great group of people and these
are warriors they fought with me
a lot they fought with me we just we
we we keep winning over there but it's
not easy right
but we get it gets easier and easier all
the time thank you very much i
appreciate
it for decades our politicians spent
trillions and trillions of dollars
rebuilding foreign nations fighting
foreign wars and defending
foreign borders just to reset because a
lot of people are asking this is a rally
in
omaha nebraska this is trump's third
rally of the day it started about i
don't know it actually it's actually
close to 40 minutes ago i think
and um i have uh put out there that
uh we can get away from the rally and i
will open up discord phone lines we just
have a membership
target and we've dropped it to 40 just
kind of casually
because it seems people do want to get
away from this i'll even change it
officially to 40 just so people see it
and um then we can just mute and we'll
pay attention and when trump starts
winding down and doing his rants we'll
go back to it but i'd be glad to hear
from some of you guys oh man it's a
great thing and
they're home from syria they're home i
left some because we kept the oil if you
don't mind there was some oil
we captured it we kept it and uh coming
home from iraq
it's enough it's enough we want to have
them all home we have a lot of other
countries too we're in many many many
countries
most of which you've never even heard of
right you've never even heard of it's
ridiculous
trump and by the way making our military
stronger by far than ever before
i ended the nafta nightmare and proudly
signed the brand new
usmca which is turning out to be
phenomenal as we know these crowds have
no idea of the difference between the
two
and the significance of that companies
will not be leaving
nebraska and iowa and all of our places
it is a very big disincentive for them
to do that
when china targeted our farmers i
delivered 28 billion dollars to our
incredible farmers here in nebraska
and iowa and all across the country
don't forget to tell the people of iowa
that please
28 billion i said to secretary sonny
perdue
of agriculture you know i said sonny
how much were the farmers targeted and
he said 12 billion sir and 16 million
two years 12 and 16.
i said 28 good so i tariffed
28 billion took it from china and
distributed it to our farmers nobody
else
nobody else is going to do this
socialism
which is bad but he's doing it people
say our farmers do better now than they
did when they actually had a farm
but we did we had the biggest order of
corn
two weeks ago in the history of our
country trump's got corn coming out the
wazoo at this point
and the biggest beef order right two
weeks ago
two weeks ago joe biden's running mate
the most liberal member of the
u.s senate you know that is right
sponsors the insane green new deal
100 trillion dollars you too can have
no windows in your building and no
toilet flush wipe out the ethanol
industry joni
that would totally wipe out that he
hasn't done the toilet flushing rant for
a little while i would love to hear it
again devastating nebraska
and devastating iowa as president i will
always defend ethanol okay
all right does nebraska like ethanol too
by the way okay good i want to just
i need that little assurance i need that
little bit of assurance
under my leadership we achieved the most
secure border in u.s history our
southern border
largely because of the wall my
opponent's insane immigration plan
would completely eliminate u.s borders
open borders they want to have let's
have open borders
so everyone can just pour it like they
used to
he would make every community into it by
the way just because this is pointless
drivel
i was reading uh the book good economics
for hard times today
and one of the really interesting things
about we've they're going back to 1980
there's been a ton of experiment
or studies done of do wages really go
down when a bunch of immigrants come in
because this is a talking point from the
right immigrants come in they're willing
to work for less wages go down
doesn't happen though doesn't actually
happen and one of the reasons is
you would think if you believe regular
supply-demand economics
if there's more supply uh all of a
sudden um
you can charge a you are you you can
charge a lower price you can pay a lower
price there's a bunch more supply you're
going to pay less
but all of the immigrants that come in
they increase demand
because not only do they work jobs they
buy stuff
they go to the grocery store they want
to compete for houses they want to
compete for cars
you understand and very interesting
chapter in in the book about it
daddy they were looking for him
we took out the world's top terrorists
solimani is dead
by the way people in the chat saying
imagine reading a book and thinking you
know
about economics i do have a bachelor's
and master's degree
in economics it's not just that i read a
book the book reminded me of it but
you know okay have fun guys and one
point this is how we get
this is how anti-intellectualism works
david do you think you know something
because
give me give me a break guys come on 150
billion or 1.8 billion in cash
i think i'm more impressed with the cash
you ever hear everything like that
that's what we gave to iran for nothing
we got nothing
i recognized the true capital of israel
and opened
american embassy insurance
and i also recognized israeli
sovereignty over the golan heights
think of that i like it when he says go
land
52 years i got it done in two hours
and instead of never-ending wars in the
middle east
you see what's happening already three
countries that we have five
lined up and we're gonna have another
it's gonna be it's an easy one
it's a lot easier earlier today when
trump was flying out he said he had
10 peace deals lined up in the middle
east people
they had the wrong concepts but uh
you know i got nominated for three nobel
peace prizes
here we go guys we do have one member
left until we open the phone
like kosovo and serbia we're doing deals
you know trade deals just normally we're
doing trade deals
i said wait a minute aren't they always
fighting each other yeah aren't they
always killing each other
for many decades or how did you know i
said i know they're killing him they
fight each other all the time tell them
we're not going to do any business with
them
they want our business right and we're
not going to do any business unless we
make a deal where they stop killing each
other
and you know what it took about 20
minutes they've been fighting for 40
years
i think they've been fighting for 400
years to one another but they've been
fighting for a long time
they want to make a deal all of a sudden
two months ago they're in the oval
office
hug into two prime minutes hugging and
kissing and thank you
[Laughter]
that was easy joe oh my god it just
makes sense
i just said hey why don't we get them
together i mean we're gonna do these two
deals
tell them to stop fighting and we save a
lot of lives that's a good thing
but we're forging peace in the middle
east without blood all over the sand and
we're not
spending money you're doing it either
it's something very nice
because we're pulling out a vote for
republicans
is a vote for the american dream it's a
vote
for acknowledgement that abraham lincoln
was a republican is that nice bit of a
misunderstanding about that history i'd
say
so in conclusion over the next four
years we will make america into the
manufacturing is he rapping already in
the world
and we will end our reliance on china
and that's already begun largely already
in conclusion
we will hire more people like a seventh
grade asset penalties for assaults or
law enforcement
and we will ban deadly sanctuary did he
say
sauce for law enforcement we will defend
religious liberty
free speech the right to life
and the right to keep and bear arms
we will maintain america's unrivaled
military might
and we will ensure peace through
strength and that's what we have now
with what we have
we will end surprise medical billing
require
price transparency that's bigger than
health care you watch
already signed kicks in on january first
how can be more drug prices even more
we sign favored nations that means we're
going to get the lowest price
anywhere in the world right now we're by
far the highest and we will also
with pre-existing conditions
[Music]
america will land the first woman on the
moon and the united states will be the
first nation to land
an astronaut on mars that's nars
g-n-a-r-s
silent g anywhere in the world again it
was a mess
three and a half years ago we will stop
the radical indoctrination of our
students
and restore patriotic education to our
school
oh dear god
we will teach our children to love our
country
honor our history and always respect
our great american flag
and we will live by the time this is
going on he's talking about flags
in god we trust
for years you had a president who
apologized to america
now you have a president who is standing
up for america
and standing up for the great people
of nebraska and iowa
so get your friends get your family get
your neighbors
and get your co-workers get your boss
and say boss
get out of here boss get out and vote
you got to vote
the red wave is coming the great red
wave
now we're doing very well those early
ballots you know the whole ballot hoax
you see what's going on there's so much
so many bad things happening but we're
doing very well
you know we're supposed to be a little
behind and then we're a little bit above
right
but that wave comes and now we go to the
front of everything
i think we're going to win everything we
didn't come this far
and fight this hard to surrender our
country back to the corrupt
washington swamp
so on november 3rd we must finish the
job that we started we have done a job
like nobody there has been no
administration nobody
but and it's us all together there has
been no administration
has done in the first three and a half
years
what this administration has done
not even close not even close
not even close from norfolk to hastings
from grand island to lincoln
and from scott's bluff to right here in
omaha
we inherit the legacy of nebraska
patriots
who gave their blood sweat and tears for
this
beloved nation we stand on the shoulders
of american heroes
who crossed the ocean settled the
continent
tamed the wilderness laid down the
railroads raised up the great
skyscrapers
won two world wars defeated fascism and
communism
and made america the single greatest
nation
in the history of the world and the best
is yet
to come it's so
stupid oh my god
is he gonna do his make america safe
again thing now
proud citizens like you helped build
this country
and together we are taking back our
country
we are returning power to you the
american people
with your help your devotion and your
drive
we are going to keep on working we are
going to keep on fighting
and we are going to keep on winning
winning winning
[Laughter]
oh my god we are one movement
one people one family and one glorious
nation
under god
[Applause]
and together with the incredible people
of nebraska
and iowa right
we have made america powerful again
we have made america wealthy again
we have made america strong again
huh we have made america proud again
that's not true we have made america
safe again
i thought it was chaos and we will make
america great again thank you nebraska
thank you iowa thank you both thank you
get out
and vote all right and then i'm assuming
we will see donald trump there it is
doing the uh stupid dance like he's
moving a hose back and forth in front of
him all right guys we did it i said 40
new members and we would open the phone
lines so you can uh
let let's hear from some people go to
davidpakman.com
discord and get into the waiting
lobby please check out the guide for how
to call
in it is literally called call in guide
our great moderation team put it
together make sure you aren't muted all
of that stuff get into the waiting lobby
change your nickname to location
colon name so for example
i am going to go first today because i
have
just a great great person here waiting i
am going to go directly to
omaha alley ally in
omaha because that's where this is so
we're going to go right to ali
oh oh boy ali is listening on a delay
there ali in omaha hello please mute the
stream and talk to me on districts
change your nickname to locate
hey ali in omaha
ally and omaha you're live
dear god
hello is this ali in omaha
yes this is ali in omaha how are you
doing good
tell me what what was going on there you
were listening on on the stream i'm
guessing and you didn't hear me
hello uh yeah um so
hello yeah you're cutting in and out uh
what's going on in omaha the president
is there right now
yeah so i want to call in i actually
used to work on political campaigns
all across nebraska and particularly in
omaha for about
five years and particularly i think it's
so hard in nebraska
um people in nebraska are so conditioned
to believe um
that republicans are better at business
that they bring
jobs but there's absolutely i mean the
evidence of that is staring them right
in the face that that's a lie where
they're celebrating pete ricketts
um his own company td ameritrade moved
their headquarters from omaha to texas
just a few years ago just yesterday they
announced that they're cutting a
thousand jobs
primarily in omaha republicans have
overseen the leaving of
conagra the ricketts family purchased a
small
pie making business in rural nebraska
and then
shut it down um so really we kind of
think of pete ricketts as our own
mini trump someone who's terrible at
business but somehow
no one notices right
excellent all right well good to know
that did you have a question today or
more of just a comment
no no more just a comment i mean
you know i think it's just interesting
seeing that president trump is here
in nebraska because in cd2 he only can
possibly win
you know one um one uh
vote that's up for grabs because we
split our electoral votes
um so it's really interesting that he's
here
yeah the fact that he's there at all is
interesting to me that a republican
seven days out is in nebraska it's
you know i'm no expert but it sounds odd
it is odd um the only times that we've
really had presidential candidates visit
is during the time when the democratic
party did
um caucuses instead of primaries right
they were able to move the date up so we
had democrats visiting
but other than that it has really not
been somewhere that people visited at
all i'm guessing they're also worried
about don bacon he's in a very
competitive election
he almost lost to cara eastman last year
so i think they're also trying to shore
that up
uh yeah a lot going on there and
certainly the crowd very very antsy for
bacon
uh earlier earlier in the rally ali
let's hope for the best in omaha
i appreciate the call yeah for sure
all right there we go ali from omaha
let's go next to there's just so many
people that want to get in
let's stay in that region of the country
let's go to casey
in nebraska casey in nebraska what's
going on
oh i'm sorry no casey in oklahoma city
casey in oklahoma city what's going on
casey in oklahoma city you're on please
unmute
casey in oklahoma city last opportunity
to talk to me
and casey in oklahoma city is gone
gone let's go to
where else are we going to go uh
what about oh this seems interesting
let's go to alex
from bolivia alex calling from bolivia
how are you
how are you doing good what's going on
not much is witnessing
comedy actually oh yeah you're at a
comedy club or you mean the rally
it's it's it's yeah the rally
yeah um now it's just interesting how
people still follow
nut jobs today yes it is it's not uh
that's it's not uniquely american but
americans do lead in it i would say
uh yeah it seems to be because i mean it
is the majority and it does and no
offense to anybody
that is republican in this chat if there
is anybody
um but yeah it's it's i mean here
even in bolivia we have socialism that's
striking but it's more like a
dictatorship
and people are well now i want to
correct one thing you said it's not
a majority in the remember more people
voted for hillary and in all certain in
all likelihood biden will also win the
popular vote so it's not a majority
right right right i mean right not a
majority
in people but that's where the flaw
falls in i'd guess that yes
electoral vote majority right
yep um but yeah no and it's funny how
it's easy to put fear of for example
socialism
when at least in most of south america
socialism is more of a dictatorship
than it is an actual socialistic um
economy because indian socialism is an
economy it's not a
political function well that that
you know that there's actually it's not
quite so clear that that's actually a
much bigger academic topic socialism
uh as a political system socialism as an
economic arrangement
the culture of socialism i mean i think
there's a lot more to that i don't think
it's quite so simple
right no no no and i agree and i agreed
to that but just the the
fear that that people in the states have
to that and they just relate it to
venezuela
or to um
brazil or to well here bolivia um
and not to other for to first work
countries such as
um i don't know uh sweden or
um what's called uh denmark or
finland or places that have yeah they're
social
socialists but they're not putting that
that dictator agenda behind it
all right alex in bolivia muchisima
gracias amigo
no recipe okay there we go
guys i know that on discord my mic
sucks there's a very specific set of
facts that
would explain why which are boring but
i'm hoping to have an additional
the problem is this mic when i use it on
discord is a disaster
um but i'm gonna get a second mic to use
on discord
and i think it'll solve a lot of these
problems all right let's go next to liz
in
indiana liz what part of indiana are you
calling in from today
oh um northeast indiana
all right northeast you know i've been
up in that area i've been to i'm going
to name
some places you tell me if they ring a
bell um
goshen ship shawana
and lagrange
lagrange was um i think about
uh 10 miles from my hometown
okay uh i currently live uh
near like fort wayne okay indianapolis a
little bit
i went to south bend got it it's a very
lovely little town
all right well what's on your mind today
there's a lot of amish when i was there
amish and evangelicals was what i was
seeing
yep uh amish are pretty cool at least
from my interactions with them
uh my dog is from an amish breeder love
my dog
um so my question is a real soft ball
okay what is uh what is the average day
of uh
david deepak pakman like what what's
what's the average day so typically i
will
uh you know i'll get up and do a little
reading and then make breakfast
and then by about 8 30 8 20 8 30
i'm at my desk working on that day's
show
and then i'm usually ready for filming
by about 10 15
10 30 we'll film until about noon
sometimes 12 15
sometimes 12 30. after that point
then it goes into business mode you know
handling the business of the show
and then about 3 3 30 i'll start working
on the next day's show and then
sometimes there's a stream
or not but that's that's the general
that's the general work day
okay you ever um get into business mode
when you're gonna do business stuff uh
i've heard some people
uh sort of describe that like even
though they work from like home
they sort of act like they're going to
work even though they're not going
anywhere so like they put on like
workshop
work shoes they like you know do some of
that work stuff
and then once work is over and they're
still at their house they take their
work shoes off
right feels like they got home from work
i i do i will
now the thing is sometimes i will wear
my all birds as work shoes and it will
confuse everybody who sees me but yes
i'm typically wearing a three-piece suit
during the business part of the day
all right brilliant thank you david all
right thank you so much there's
liz from indiana very very nice
let's go next to where do we want to go
uh let's go to sarah from
sioux city sarah from sioux city
hi can you hear me yes i can
hi
how are you i don't really have any
questions but i just wanted to say um
during this whole you know these past
couple months me and my dad we've been
relying on you for all our news and
i just i just want to thank you for
everything you've been doing and
you know giving us you know up-to-date
news and all the facts
and you're not being you know biased
you're
just and you're telling it great i just
want to say thank you thank you so much
that's so nice of you to say
oh i guess sarah's gone sarah for feel
good call of the year
there it is okay let's try something
else now
let's go to um let's go to spencer from
cleveland spencer for cleve from
cleveland what's going on
hey man what's going on how you how you
doing
good i just had a couple of comments on
the thing first
no masks i know not
and nebraska's numbers are spiking
secondly
yeah secondly um
both nebraska's i want to know what
sorry you're you're cutting in and out
you want to know what about nebraska
he said both nebraska's where did he get
that
oh i think he means some people thought
he meant
the dakotas i assume he's talking about
the fact that nebraska
has some electoral votes that are for
each
they're assigned at the district level i
assume that's what he meant
okay that makes sense i mean but maybe
he thought he was in south dakota who
knows and he was talking about the
dakotas who knows
yeah i mean with him it's everything and
nothing at the same time
right yeah and i mean
it's it's the weirdest thing ever and
it's it's very unsettling to
you know just watch it happen it is very
much unsaid i i have a feeling next
tuesday
will be a high anxiety day but um
we will hopefully get to the better side
of it eventually
yeah for sure i mean i'm voting election
day and i mean i'm voting biden
all right very good i appreciate hearing
from you thank you very very much
let's go next to solange
from miami who tried to call in last
time and there was some kind of issue
and she was muted and it got crazy
solange from miami are you able to
redeem yourself today
i hope so can you hear me i can hear you
loud and clear solange
awesome okay great the reason i'm
calling is i guess i want
some kind of i guess i want someone to
make me feel better because i felt for
months
i was so certain that biden was gonna
win
all the trumpers that i knew had seemed
to not a hundred percent turn against
him but they
realized he was doing a horrible job
with covid
the unemployment
are you editing video as you talk to me
it sounds like you're editing video as
you talk to me
maybe um maybe it's my youtube is that
better
that is better yeah okay sorry so
now it seems like they're all running
home to daddy again
like all of a sudden it's like trump
signs popped up everywhere
all over miami all the people that i
knew that were
saying uh that desantis and trump were
doing a horrible job are all now saying
the exact opposite and i just feel like
i don't think we're going to win anymore
they're they're circling the wagons is
what they're doing they're in this
country
they're circling the wagons i can't say
hello they're circling the wagons that's
what's
what's going on and they would rather
deal with trump
than see a democrat win in the end you
know susan collins is disappointed
and lisa murkowski's saddened but
they're all gonna do what they're all
gonna do and and we're just gonna have
to beat them and
and either we do or we don't but you
know it was always going to be this way
solange
do you think we will if you say bet
right now
even odds i say biden wins if you make
me bet now i still think
trump has a very strong shot at winning
uh but if you say
even odds just make a bet i bet biden
wins
everyone please please go out and vote
absolutely absolutely florida will be a
very powerful state taking my call
my pleasure there is solange from miami
uh we are going to go next to
uh christian from arizona christian from
arizona what's going on
hey david can hear me yes i can what's
going on christian
uh not much i actually just discovered
you today and it seems like all these
other people
have been watching for a while and i've
been missing out but i appreciate you
first off for just doing the stream kind
of doing what you're doing
but i wanted to ask you if you thought
that things would be going differently
the same or worse if somebody like
bernie sanders or pete bourgeois were up
here
as the nominee at this point in the race
would we be seeing the same type of
thing that we're seeing right now or do
you think would be vastly different i
think that those
types of questions cannot be answered
definitively
and can only serve to divide the left i
think all we know is
biden won the primary not by a little
but by a lot
and he's ahead in the polling right now
that's really
all we know and you know people will
email me and they'll say bernie would be
doing better
people email me and they say what's
wrong with the bernie people saying
bernie would be doing better bernie
couldn't even beat joe biden how's he
going to beat donald trump
i don't think we gain really anything at
this late stage in the game
from uh what is really just speculation
in the end i mean we just we just don't
know
yeah that's actually pretty fair to say
like you know what i will say though
let me just say one thing at the end of
the day it isn't worth it let me say one
thing
the people who write to me and they say
tulsi would be winning if she had been
the nominee
i think they're wrong i think with pete
edge edge or bernie sanders you know
i i don't know the answer i don't think
we it's really knowable
i don't think tulsi would have been
crushing trump right now
sure yeah that's what you're saying i
just want to ask you one more thing
sure how you feel about you know the
potential that he obviously doesn't win
and we go into that next phase of like a
hidden side of politics that people
don't typically know
about where it's like we're worried
about the next phase of like him not
deciding to leave does that worry you a
lot or
you feel like he eventually will just
concede in you know
typical politics like we have seen if
biden wins trump will go
and he will go thrashing and screaming
and i will love every minute of watching
it
i agree that's fair all right thanks
very much for the call uh first
first day viewer even and we were able
to uh to hear from him which is very
exciting
let's just do a couple of others um how
about we go to amari from south texas
amari from south texas you are on
hi can you hear me yes i can
oh hi david i've been watching you uh
religiously uh for the past like month
or so thank you i have two questions for
you
sure um what would you do if you saw
donald trump uh if you saw him on the
street or whatever by himself
and uh how would you react like if you
were close to him
would you ask for a picture would you
tell him something what would you do
i i have no idea that it's it's so
unlikely
that i have to admit i've not thought
about what i would do i don't think i
would see him by himself especially
since he'll have
secret service protection for the rest
of his life so i i'd have to think about
that amari
okay um all right and my second question
is
what would you tell um i live in in the
border
and there are certainly a lot of
undocumented
immigrants in here and what would you
tell um someone who wants to get
involved
but is not able to vote because of
him or her being undocumented
how to get involved in a campaign
yeah just like the election
election-wise like um
since uh you know a lot of people are
not able to
vote themselves even though i would say
probably phone banking
oh okay yeah um thank you very much
um david uh it's been a pleasure very
strongly
very strong pleasure thank you the the
pleasure is very strong on this side of
the microphone i very
very much appreciate it um all right
let's go now down to
uh why don't we go to david from
richmond virginia
david from richmond virginia you're on
yes i can
so i know this probably isn't like a big
there aren't many
single-issue space policy voters but i'm
wondering is biden really said anything
about that
said anything about what space policy
oh i thought you said there isn't space
for
single issue oh i miss uh no i
i don't think i've really heard biden
say much about space policy to be
perfectly frank
um people in the chat can correct me but
nothing is standing out to me
i i don't think i mean you know trump's
been inserting this one-liner about
going to nars
um recently and maybe maybe that's
enough to bring the space vote over to
trump but no i've not really heard very
much from uh from biden on it
yeah um as far as i what i think i think
he should
probably continue the artemis program
because i don't think that's something
trump really had much
input on we need a complete rethink we
need a paradigm shift on space policy to
be perfectly frank
we need to be looking at uh asteroid
uh asteroid uh what am i talking about
here
harnessing the resources of asteroids
asteroid mining
we need to be looking at a serious
program to go back to the moon we want
to go to mars we want
there's all sorts of different things we
should be doing we should be looking at
what opportunities are there for
geostationary orbital elements
that could be doing different things um
i want i want it all
i'm not so concerned about space weapons
and space
war at this time though
yeah all right thank you for taking the
question all right my pleasure thank you
very much
all right guys that's gonna do it for me
so glad i was able to hear from a whole
bunch of you
as always uh you can join the discord
davidpakman.com
slash discord thank you so much and we
will hear from you again very soon i am
sure
you